well the streets of Henderson are once
again a pain and agreeing at hundreds
flocked to the iconic Water Street
District here in Henderson to celebrate
the return of the iconic and loved and
missed St Patrick Day Parade
any parade that leads off with eight
bagpipe players to start with is great
the 55th annual Saint Patrick's Day Fest
and parade has water sheep glowing green
with energy once again Saturday's parade
featured Celtic dancing appearances by
Community Heroes and more it was action
all the way through I just loved it the
parade is the second day of the
three-day festival with Irish step dance
performances classic cars a carnival and
food it's easy to understand this year's
theme Green With Envy it is wonderful
good turnout here with everybody that
kids are having a great time right James
yeah Festival goers tell me it was tough
when the family-friendly event was on
Hiatus during the pandemic it was very
sad because you know the kids need to be
out the kids need to see and enjoy and
celebrate holidays so to not have that
was really sad now back in full swing
the Luck of the Irish is helping Nevada
once again in more ways than one
Festival goers can help fight Childhood
Cancer by participating in Saint Paul
aldricks going green with love
puppies and the streets will continue to
stay busy and just like this for another
two days 55th annual St Patrick's Day
Festival and parade wraps up today at 10
but as a back on and popping here in
Water Street Plaza from noon to 7 00 p.m
of course we got you covered with all
the details on how you can enjoy down
here at Water Street on our website in
newsnow.com for now in Henderson I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now